my name is Peter welcome to Friday with
being a face
[Music]
how's going bros my name is and welcome
to actually recorded this on another
camera but the battery night sir
it's gonna be a little bit different i
got a lot of cool messages from you bros
since open the peel box i'm surprised i
got so many actually cuz it's only been
a couple days so I thought why not open
it here and this Christmas movie though
first off I have some things I already
open and already show but why not show
them again you haven't seen them yet
first was a drawing of the fauna there
it is and on the back side it says plays
brofist on yeah that's an awkward though
but it was made by Auto frisk and Don
Larson thank you very much brother
this one had a really cool I guess you
probably can't sit I'll probably show
edit in the real one but she has a
really cool drawing so I really it was
really funny to all add it dude but it's
really awesome that you send it to me
it's really funny too I love the barrel
that's sure so bridges this looks
exciting Beauty productions Royal Mail
it's not from the UK
oh ye these I don't know what is this -
Felix I might say that's a really
awesome fan arc it's really cool it's
printed out it's a CD a no wait it's
something else
I thought it was a CD oh is a Christmas
kick
Agee yo-ho-ho Peary it's obvious there's
not that good you which means America's
from Lea I'm Italian
Alessandra NATO that's kind of cool
oh no get there I got prey I guess
and that's picky for anything on that I
have assumed that's picky yeah it says a
poem pretty high I made a little thing
for you if you show this in some of your
videos can you please link it for me
sure I'll do it Danny's design you can
see it there it is alright that's a lot
of tape I should've brought us oh wow
really
oh wow this is awesome
look at that is really simplifies you
did an amazing job
look at that Stephanie even gave him
like a scarf because that's baby
this is awesome I finally have my
Stefano yeah but I don't have to be
afraid from anything put him here okay
you should hit him everywhere
all right it's like what a a dyke anyway
next son it's from Finland Susan for
strim another a gift could it be another
Stefano
I'm really good at opening gifts
hey it's a shock
I'm definitely eating this I love
chocolate it's a Swedish joke if they
ask are you finished
no I'm sweetie hmm and she also got me a
awesome bro
keychain awesome mint Oh
there's a broker chain things on Susan
many brofist to you this one is kind of
weird it says has a job base all right
why did we get Wow super long letter but
it's from politic town evolved Wow they
want to do like behind the scenes or
whatever for me and we'll discuss it
probably make it one of these days he
lives in my area yeah anyway thanks for
the letter in the trunk based politic
yeah alright I got one more it's an
awesome drawing but I have made don't
let a pity just don't make a nice it's
an awesome drawing you probably can't
see thanks a lot anyway thanks a lot for
all these awesome letters and chocolate
it's the fun of me he's proud you want
to send me stuff I'll leave a link in
the description and I'll probably open
it in another video thanks a lot for
watching Bros Merry Christmas Happy New
Year's and all I kind of stuff from
mater the why don't you talent from i
Simon and I wish you a Merry Christmas
as well that's awkward
that's pretty much it oh yeah then lick
with a professed all right are you ready
bros one two three Merry Christmas
profit
[Music]